hey so I have a Keurig on the table with
me and I want to make super clear that
this is not a product placement this is
not an advertising of any kind in fact I
don't like Keurig machines but I do have
a Keurig machine on the desk with me
today what's the backstory of this you
might remember that there was this rash
of videos by conservatives angrily
destroying and setting on fire their
Keurig machines after Keurig pulled
advertising from Sean Hannity's FoxNews
TV show when he sort of seemed to defend
Roy more by saying at least some of his
victims had consented to sexual contact
with Roy more and conservatives went
crazy destroying their Keurigs now it's
no secret that I have serious disdain
for the coffee of Keurig machines I
think it's absolutely terrible coffee
well Matt a viewer got in touch with me
and he said hey David listen I just
switched from a Keurig to one that makes
good coffee I was just gonna toss this
but I thought since Keurigs come up on
your program maybe I would send you the
used Keurig machine he insisted on
sending it in and now we have it so the
question is what do we do do we destroy
the Keurig machine not for anything
having to do with Sean Hannity's program
but simply because the Keurig makes bad
coffee some people might think we were
destroying it over the Hannity thing
which I guess that would be kind of the
fun of it if people thought that's why
we were destroying it and it turns out I
just don't think cure eggs make good
coffee the other side of it like the
really boring thing to do would be we
just give the Keurig to Pat because he
likes keyrings yeah big fan of Keurig
over here although the audience isn't
going to decide that I mean they'd much
rather see you destroy it or me destroy
it item or something else better
entertainment so my question is what
else could we do with this Keurig
machine that's been donated we've
acquired it at no cost right so we can
destroy it we can do whatever the the
lost value of it is not an issue matt
has generously donated it donated it and
said do whatever you want
destroy it set it on fire blow it up or
just give it to Pat so he can make
coffee I'm open to hearing suggestions
from the audience so that's why I'm
talking about this today the Keurig is
sitting here with me if you have any
ideas of what we might be able to do
with this thing that would be funny
might help fundraise or whatever we
could give away a signed keyring if
someone wanted it with some fundraising
goal I have no idea I don't know if this
will put the Keurig scandal to rest or
just reopen the next chapter right I
think if you destroyed a Keurig it might
end this entire sort of love affair that
has caused so much controversy between
you and keyring if you were willing to
destroy it would be a ritual wouldn't it
the question is what would you destroy
it with like a baseball bat or bare
hands with your bare hands how else
could a Keurig be destroyed I don't know
there's a whole video people setting it
on fire set it on drawing on your pool
yeah I don't know what I don't know ours
running it over with a car would be
interesting actually yeah so send in
your thoughts we'll do something with
this but I don't know what what people
want us to do and if what you want is
for Pat to take the keurig and for me to
never mention it again that's also an
acceptable path forward right we're sort
of open to that as well